you want to do something for tom petty
and in memories of uh yeah let's do that
what's the song you love from
tom petty that you uh prepared
wildflowers and the reason why i chose
this song is i think again it's about
it's hopeful
it's hopeful rather than mourning and i
think that's the way that i like to
stay you know it is like you deserve to
be free and i think
there's a lyric in my one of my songs
that says something like you know
um death is life it's not a curse
it reminds us of time and what it's
worth so
it is weird with tom petty right i mean
he was a guy i wouldn't expect to i just
it wasn't on my radar that he would die
it's just so sudden and weird and
upsetting this is a reason i mean
sometimes if
if you're ever free and want to go see a
show we should we should all make sure
we go see more
music right we got to go see more live
shows it is uplifting it is
we have to go see more shows because
you're going to wish that you did
what else is more important yeah is the
band ready we just came up with this
last night so we'll
try it out we'll see how it goes
[Music]
you belong somewhere you feel
free
run away and find you a lover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no
[Music]
and you belong with your love
on your own you belong
somewhere you feel free
[Music]
hello
[Music]
run away and go find a lover
run away let your heart be your guide
and you deserve the deepest
you belong among the wild flowers
you belong somewhere close to me
far away from troubles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll feel
free
got me teary-eyed what a beautiful
tribute to tom petty
uh he would have liked that i know that
you